[Music]
at the lake Queen's funeral a motion met
with pure strength
the monarchs coffin moved through
Central London on the state's ceremonial
gun Carriage weighing two and a half
tons it was pulled by 98 Royal Navy
sailors at the front was commander
Nicola Crips we were unsure if it was
going to be lots of Applause or lots of
silence as it was as the funeral Cortez
passed through the crowds fell silent
and the connection between people became
very apparent individuals would reach
out and touch each other as they saw the
gun Carriage pass
today at Windsor Castle the Royal Navy
personnel involved were awarded Medals
of the royal Victorian order presented
by the king its recognition for those
who serve the monarchy in a personal way
on a day that for sailor Jessica King
combined public duty with private grief
I actually lost my own mother
not too many weeks prior to the training
commencing and obviously losing the
queen herself the boss essentially was
an enormous loss so therefore
emotionally the day was
was probably at its highest
in the ranks today was medical assistant
Paisley Chambers Smith now seven months
pregnant
it's massive uh massive honor to be here
I've only been in three years so to have
got a medal so soon such a big medal is
the Royal Navy like other arms of the
military planned the Queen's funeral for
years but in the end it came down to
little over a week of intense training
to make a Herculean task look so precise
we had 10 days in which the from start
to finish to get everybody in uniform
and trained at the right level for for
obviously for the for the funeral on the
10th day and I think I could probably
speak for everyone that we're absolutely
you know honored and privileged to be
here today
the medals received today are an honor
and also a reminder of a moment in
history and of the roles they all played
Catherine phototsi Sky News